bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo l'émission lcp public sénat qui
refait le tour de l'actualité politique
et parlementaire bonjour michaëlle jean
chrétien et cette semaine françois
hollande a renoncé à la mesure qu'il a
prôné le lendemain des attentats du 13
novembre il n'y aura pas de déchéance de
nationalité pour les terroristes
présumés terroristes le chef de l'état a
pris acte de l'échec du parlement a
adopté un texte le commun pas de
révision constitutionnelle la mini du
travail a défendu son texte devant les
députés en commission le texte qui
réforme le code du travail est très
contesté une nouvelle manifestation a
réuni des centaines de milliers de
personnes dans les rues
et puis après les députés les sénateurs
ont examiné le projet de loi qui prévoit
de nouvelles mesures antiterroristes et
réforme la procédure pénale feu vert
pour la perpétuité incompressible pour
les auteurs de crimes terroristes
notre invité cette semaine pour
commenter toute cette actualité bonjour
la rue mariton bonjour vous êtes député
les républicains de la drôme candidat
pour la primaire de votre parti les
républicains et auteur de ce livre
le printemps des libertés les réformes
qui sauveront la france on va en parler
avec jim jara scène d'autres partenaires
du figaro ça sera en fin d'émission
mais katia a commencé par une polémique
oui polémique lancée par le ministre des
sports patrick kanner c'est lundi
le ministre qui a évoqué la présence en
france d'une centaine de molenbeek lé
premier ministre qui a donc lancé la
polémique jordan klein c'est une phrase
lancée ce week end qui a créé la
polémique il y a aujourd'hui on le sait
une centaine de quartiers en france qui
présente des similitudes potentiel avec
ce qui s'est passé à molenbeek
pour le ministre molenbeek c'est aussi
une concentration de pauvreté de chômage
et de dérive ultra communautariste des
aspects que l'on retrouverait dans
certaines villes françaises entre
stigmatisation et lucidité
les élus de droite applaudissent une
prise de conscience de la part du
gouvernement un peu de langage de vérité
ne nuit pas donc quelqu'un qui dit il ya
des quartiers difficiles sensible où on
a laissé s'installer le communautarisme
et faut être franc gouvernement de
gauche ou de droite mais ce caennais
devrait aller au bout du raisonnement
le cabinet du ministre a tenu à
justifier ces chiffres selon lui il
s'agit de quartier cumulant les
handicaps sociaux figurant sur la liste
des zones prioritaires
à gauche les politiques sont plus
mesurés et pointe du doigt des amalgames
ces quartiers il faut continuer à leur
proposer un nouvel avenir
mais ils ne font pas non plus
stigmatiser et dire voilà c'est un
quartier difficile donc stimule donc
stigmatisation donc radicalisation donc
terrorisme parce que dans ce cas là on
va mettre en cause des millions de
personnes qui n'y sont pour rien
aujourd'hui devant les députés
socialistes manuel valls a approuvé les
propos de son ministre
même si le chef du gouvernement a jugé
difficile les comparaisons
hervé mariton est ce que vous diriez
vous aussi comme patrick kanner qu'il ya
des molenbeek en france et combien
oui oui parce que c'est l'analyse que
les politiques lucine faisons oui parce
que quand j'écoute des experts comme
gilles kepel qui trouve que pour
l'essentiel le propos de patrice scanner
est juste et oui il y a des quartiers
qui ne sont pas sous un contrôle
suffisant en termes de sécurité des
quartiers dans lequel parfois les
municipalités elle-même encourage le
communautarisme
des quartiers qui du fait d'une
politique de l'urbanisme de l'habitat
mal calibré se sont transformés en
ghettos dans les propositions de mon
livre je propose de changer le concept
de logement social de l'abandonner tel
qu'il a été construit en france parce
qu'ils amènent des municipalités à
construire parfois 50% 62 181 penser
qu'au problème est là en sociaux le
problème n'est pas uniquement là mais ça
y contribue
s'il y avait davantage de variétés s'il
y avait davantage un libre choix du
logement pour les personnes modestes
aide à la personne plutôt qu'eads à la
pierre s'il y avait des communes qui de
ce fait est une meilleure diversité mais
pas au sens du politiquement correct
telle qu'on la leur aux naïfs comme le
dit michel sapin oui oui c'est exact à
propos de la belgique mais ce qu'on
pourrait nommer clientéliste à la fois
le modèle leaf est aimable en réalité
parce que dans certains cas l'état a
reculé en conscience aux claques
mauvaise conscience mais évidemment
laxisme des municipalités qui au fond
ont délégué le contrôle et la paix
sociale des vous savez à toutes ces
pratiques et art en ferait l'égal donc
on s'est beaucoup flatté pendant
quelques années alors que les grands
frères en réalité c'est une espèce
d'intermédiaires pas bien clair pas bien
heureux entre la délinquance et la loi
de la république hier et s'est fait à
droite gauche peu importe à la limite
non pas peu importe mais la droite et la
gauche dans une mauvaise compréhension
de la politique de la ville
ida qu'il y ait une politique de la
ville comme l'évoquent de cette manière
jean pierre sueur qu'on doive être
attentif à des efforts à la promotion à
la solution de difficultés de certains
quartiers évidemment oui notre reste
donc la politique de la ville telle
qu'elle a été menée jusqu'à présent
suffit de regarder les résultats
oui donc le fait qu'il y ait une
politique de la ville est quelque chose
de tout à fait bienvenu nécessaire mais
il faut mais il faut le faire avec moins
de naïveté
il faut le faire sans considérer que la
seule que le seul versement d'une mam
règlerait le problème
on voit bien que le financement
d'associations qui parfois ont éloigné
de la solution plus qu'elles n'en ont
rapproché n'était pas heureux et que
la politique de concentration urbaine
logements sociaux sur l'agent sociaux
est aussi un échec mois passés au mardi
je voulais bien mariton avec la ministre
du travail qui était devant les députés
niamey les cobras était donc devant la
commission des affaires sociales qui
avait fait le plein c'est vrai ce mardi
le grand oral donc pour myriam el khomri
on regarde ce reportage
une ministre enthousiaste qui se targue
de défendre une loi équilibré avec un
objectif principal
réformer profondément notre droit du
travail en donnant beaucoup plus de
place à la négociation collective
mais le rapporteur n'est pas du même
avis le projet de loi pour lui nécessite
encore des précisions notamment pour
rassurer les salariés
s'il est vrai que le contexte au new
economic demande aux entreprises de
pouvoir s'adapter
le contexte économique doit aussi
prendre en compte le fait que les
salariés sont inquiets pour leur avenir
dans l'opposition un mot d'ordre revenir
au texte initial
mais la droite salue quelques
dispositions avec une certaine ironie
saluons les circonvolutions ac auquel
vous vous êtes vous prêter pour remettre
en cause des 35 heures sans le dire et
entre la possibilité de négocier des
taux de majoration des heures
supplémentaires autour de 10% des
accords offensif
les communistes dénoncent le la
philosophie même du texte
la vocation initiale du code du travail
est la protection des salariés ce n'est
pas une modernisation qu'il s'agit mais
d'un retour en arrière pour ne pas dire
très en arrière
l'examen du texte commencera le 4 avril
en commission avant le coup d'envoi dans
l'hémicycle le 3 mai prochain
alors on va rester sur le fond on
abordera les questions socio de
notamment des manifestations un petit
peu plus tard j'imagine que le libéral
que vous êtes et on au programme
beaucoup de choses dans votre livre on
va dire que cette loi ne va pas assez
loin
oui je dis que c'est pas assez loin une
fois qu'on a dit ça oui jusqu'où ou
est-ce qu'on pourrait aller c'est par
exemple sur les tpe les pme seule petite
entreprise les moyennes entreprises il
paraît que le gouvernement pourrait
bouger ce que ça pourrait vous
satisfaire et moi ce que je souhaiterais
c'est qu' il y ait la plus grande
liberté possible dans l'entreprise c'est
ça mon approche de liberté pas
ce que je crois que beaucoup de choses
peuvent se régler dans l'entreprise et
ma vision c'est ce principe de
subsidiarité qui m'inspire beaucoup
si on veut trouver une solution dans
l'entreprise on le trouve dans
l'entreprise si on peut la trouver dans
la branche retrouve dans la branche
et si ça n'est pas possible alors il ya
un droit du travail qui est là pour
résoudre les situations mais cette idée
qui est l'idée sur laquelle est que
voulez vous en effet vous laisse de côté
le code du travail
je suis mal et que salariés vont
accepter cela mais si les salariés
acceptent alors c'est que chacun y
trouve son compte
l'employeur les salariés et ça définit
une manière de faire dans l'entreprise
je vais pas disparaître toute règle il
ya ce qu'on appelle l'ordre social
public assez largement définie par des
textes européens aujourd'hui je ne
propose pas de faire sauter l'ordre
social public mais je dis que le code du
travail tel qu'il existe depuis des
décennies en france qui est dans l'idée
totalement de protéger le faible
salariés supposément opprimés par
l'entreprise ça ne fonctionne pas cette
manière là aujourd'hui et chaque fois
qu'un accord peut être trouvé alors cet
accord doit prévaloir sans qu'il y ait
une contrainte supplémentaire d'un code
du travail
et là où il n'y a pas à coop il y a un
code subsidiaire supplétifs qui permet
de résoudre la situation vous avez vous
avez un modèle ailleurs en europe est ce
que ce serait suivre la voie qu'a suivi
par exemple matteo renzi en italie ou
plutôt un modèle à l'allemande ou alors
un autre modèle c7 une vision
franchement neuf qui est celle de
l'accord local qui en effet est plus
proche de ce qui existe dans d'autres
pays qui n'ont pas les mêmes contraintes
que le code du travail très rigide à la
française mais c'est inventer quelque
chose de neuf parce que nous savons les
ports un nouvel comparé vraiment de la
base de du constat d'un consentement
parfois ça prend du temps donc à ce
moment là il ya un code du travail qui
continue de s'appliquer tant qu'on n'a
pas trouvé une solution
localement si on la trouve c'est
l'accord local qui définit sous réserve
de leur social public et si on ne la
trouve pas alors il ya de nouveau un
code du travail supplétifs mais bien que
le monde du travail changent la pratique
du travail le goût du travail
les gens ne sont pas nécessairement à
leur boulot 24 35 heures sur 35 ou 40
heures sur 40
et puis le temps de travail la réalité
c'est qu'on continue de tourner autour
de ce débat des 35 heures et welcome
lycée les dérogations autour d'une règle
pourri les 35 heures oui parce que un le
temps de travail en france globalement
est insuffisant mais deux les réponses
sont très variables
il ya des boîtes où on peut trouver une
réponse
32 heures ou à 30 heures tant mieux il
ya des entreprises où on peut trouver
une réponse à 42 heures étant au final
four le chat non je le voterai part et
d'autre part je voterai pas parce qu'ils
étaient insuffisantes et le départ de
mon point de vue est qu'il est encore
plus lacunaire aujourd'hui j'ajoute que
la réponse que je propose je pensais et
la bonne réponse parce que elle elle
encadre une vision une vision qui donne
un espoir aux gens une autre forme de
relation au travail
et si vous n'êtes pas dans la vision si
vous êtes dans la mesure purement
paramétrer type telles conneries alors
vous avez des manifs
alors on reparlera de votre vision tout
à l'heure d'abord je vous propose à
mardi de voir l'actualité de votre party
les républicains qui a tenu son bureau
politique à l'ordre du jour le
changement de certaines règles pour les
primaires seuls les parlementaires de
droite pourront parrainer les candidats
écoutez la réaction de nathalie
kosciusko morizet à la sortie du bureau
ces modifications qui est proposée par
des acteurs qui sont eux mêmes impliqués
dans la primaire candidats aux futurs
candidats et c'est un mauvais présage
que s'organisait ainsi pour changer les
règles du jeu à son profit est ce que je
retiens c'est qu'on cherche par des
mesures administratives à écarter ma
candidature je trouve pas qu'il soit
légitime de chercher dans une primaire
ouverte à écarter une candidature par
des mesures administratives alors vous
étiez présent lors de ce bureau
politique vous avez vous été pourquoi
vous me suis abstenu je suis venu parce
que sur le fond demandé que les
parlementaires qui paraît une
candidature adhèrent aux valeurs de la
droite et du centre les parlementaires
sans les centristes peuvent parrainer
parlementaires centristes peuvent
parrainer si on nous explique demain que
les parlementaires centristes peuvent
pas parrainer passe mal ça fait exploser
le système est un moment si on se fout
de la règle des primaires à un moment il
finira par y avoir des candidats en
dehors les primaires il faut tout de
même que aux républicains on est aride
est atteint oui oui parce que batterie
soit la règle est respectée et je vais
revenir là dessus
dans son esprit et dans sa forme et des
statuts ça se respecte
quand il ya quelques mois jean temps un
mec collègues au bureau politique de
l'ump
à l'époque encore expliqué les statuts
on s'en fout on est là pour faire la
politique
quand mardi soir nicolas sarkozy me
répond mais hervé on n'est pas là pour
faire du juridisme jeudi faut faire
gaffe
il ya un niveau d'adaptation qui est
convenable je me suis abstenu je veux
dire pour
mais il ya un niveau au delà duquel les
respect de la règle comment serait
apposée de 5,12 la galerie bleue
crédibilité politique c'est pas que ça
m'agace c'est tout un vrai sujet c'est
quelque chose que vous semblez arrivée
la primaire n'a de sens que pour autant
que la règle soit solide et said
maristes et qu'est-ce que vous avez la
buzzer n'est pas solide est pas
respectée je vous réponds s'agissant du
vote de mardi soir prié de dire mais
pourrait vous ai pas voté contre je suis
abstenu parce que sur le fond l'idée de
demander aux parrains d'accomplir la
même formalité des électeurs de dire
qu'ils adhèrent aux valeurs de la droite
et du centre
ça me paraît cohérent et pourquoi j'ai
pas voté pour parce que un changement
même cohérent de la règle est quelque
chose qui demande une infinie prudence
et je ne veux pas qu'on en rajoute trop
demain voilà c'est extrêmement clair je
vous donne un exemple de terrain lors
d'une mise en garde que vous faites oui
oui la réponse est oui
quand nous avons fixé une règle qui est
que les animateurs locaux les présidents
locaux des comités de gestion des
primaires ne doivent pas être en même
temps secrétaires départementaux des
républicains il a fallu que je démontre
dans un département cette règle
n'étaient pas respectés pour que l'on
s'en inquiète et qu'on demande
effectivement aux secrétaires
départementaux alors de renoncer à leurs
fonctions
en tout cas de choisir donc voila moi je
suis dans l'exercice dont je passe pas
mon temps à protester de la règle je
demande simplement simplement sur le
respect de la règle qui visez vous
exactement qui aurait intérêt
aujourd'hui à changer les règles
mais je vise large ça va me faire que
notre conversion politique a un sens
assez relatif de la règle la phrase que
je vous ai relaté qui est les statuts
qui par une phrase d'aujourd'hui c'était
il ya quelques mois s'était encore le mp
les statuts on s'en fout on est là pour
faire de la politique est une phrase en
réalité qu'on entend souvent et on voit
bien quand en bureau politique on
argumente sur la règle et sur les
statuts bien sombre de gens qui lisent
hervé était gentil mais si on pouvait
qu'amener la réunion plus vite ce serait
mieux vous vous dites ça suffit je dis
qu'il faut un respect convenable de la
règle est repassé mercredi françois louw
lagarde est la règle je rappelle la mère
supérieure donne avec des carmélites
c'est moi qui garde la règle
serait de garder ces tueries solaire qui
gardent pour l'instant levade si je peux
me permettre c'est au tour du pin c'est
important parce que pour la présidence
de l'ump j'ai été candidat en novembre
2014 anne levade responsables présents
de la haute autorité a parfaitement su
faire valoir règle je souhaite pour la
primaire qu'il soit très clair que
l'autorité c'est anne levade ce n'est
pas thierry et on va parler de la règle
suprême maintenant oui françois hollande
recadre c'est la fin de la révision
constitutionnelle
voilà plusieurs mois de débats plusieurs
polémiques et puis des fractures dont
chaque camp à droite comme à gauche est
plus présent de la république qui a pris
ses responsabilités qui a dit que rapid
e révision constitutionnelle on voit
tout cela qu'est ramona gamme à 5
minutes d'allocution qui signe la fin de
quatre mois de débat autour de la
révision constitutionnelle
je constate aujourd'hui quatre mois
après que l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat ne sont pas parvenus à se mettre
d'accord sur un même texte et qu'un
compromis par mm hors d'atteinte sur la
définition de la déchéance de
nationalité pour les terroristes
aussi j'ai décidé après m'être entretenu
avec les présidents de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat de clore le débat
constitutionnel pour être présenté à
versailles il fallait que la réforme
soit adoptée dans les mêmes termes par
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
les socialistes rejettent en bloc la
faute sur l'opposition et notamment la
droite sénatoriale
nous n'avons pas convaincu la droite en
général et la droite sénatoriale en
particulier de rentrer dans l'union
nationale pour renforcer notre roi dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme et
l'opposition n'entend pas être tenu pour
responsable de cet échec
elle le rappelle la version votée par le
sénat c'est presque la même que la
version initiale du gouvernement
présenté en décembre dernier
républicains étaient décidés à voter
la déchéance de nationalité pour les
binationaux
monsieur hollande nous avait proposé la
déchéance pour les binationaux
puis est arrivé l'histoire du retrait de
la nationalité pour les nationaux mais
monsieur ça n'a aucun sens
quatre mois de déchirures qui laisseront
des traces surtout dans la majorité
cette annonce est il à un échec
personnel pour françois hollande ou y at
il une responsabilité collective
c'est un échec pour françois hollande
simplement je suis de ceux qui parmi les
premiers ont eu le courage de dire parce
que c'est une position assez minoritaire
à l'époque oui que c'est d'échanger
shalit était une proposition qui n'avait
aucun sens s'il fallait la con partie ce
que mais surtout que des chances de
nationalité serait une mesure inopérante
inefficace qui n'est pas une manière
intelligente de réponde aux terroristes
qui s'en fichent qui voire même pouvait
être flatté d'une réponse politique de
cette nature au terrorisme
on répond par d'une mise en cause du
criminel qu'elle terroriste la réponse
aux terroristes aller sur le terrain
criminel on criminalise le terroriste et
on ne lui donne pas un statut politique
par regret de ne pas avoir révisé la
constitution au mois peut-être sur
l'état d'urgence dans l'état d'urgence
on voit bien que l'état d'urgence et mis
en oeuvre aujourd'hui dans des
conditions utile sans qu'il y ait besoin
de réviser la constitution
donc là il en a conscience pour l'état
d'urgence n'est pas utile la déchéance
de nationalité est une très mauvaise
mesure
c'est en plus l'exemple même du symbole
pour rien et nicolas sarkozy qui a
beaucoup soutenu cette mesure en disant
il faut des symboles a eu tort aussi
parce que un symbole qui n'ont breil sur
aucune réalité concrète
un symbole qu il embraye sur aucun
progrès tangibles dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme et c'est le cas de cette
mesure qui est de la comme la déchéance
de nationalité
alors le symbole à un moment s'est fondé
sur l'humain donc céder celle de bronze
en hollande et nicolas sarkozy bien sûr
vous entends bien oui parce que cette
mesure a été porté par ceux qui ont
voulu faire de la com com françois
hollande sur un sujet aussi considérable
comme agir et celles et ceux qui n'ont
pas osé dire
la vérité ce qu'ils ont considéré que
dès lors qu'il y avait un mot viril
vigoureux fort en apparence il fallait
embrayé parce que faut suivre le
mouvement
et ben non la politique de temps en
temps ça suppose de l'honnêteté ça
suppose de la lucidité ça suppose du
courage et de la pédagogie
françois hollande a été dans la com
nicolas sarkozy avait embrayé ce moment
là j'ai fait partie des quelques uns ont
eu le courage de dire la vérité dès le
début alors trois heures après cette
annonce manuel valls a fustigé l' 8
devant la représentation nationale
la main tant de la latitude pardon de la
droite sénatoriale a écouté la droite
sénatoriale s'oppose à une mesure que
les français ont parfaitement compris
l'extension mais c'est en fait on est
coach arrêt de la déchéance de la
nationalité pour les terroristes qui
prennent les armes pour tuer leurs
propres compatriotes
une mesure une mesure voulue par
l'opposition une mesure que le président
la république et l'exécutif dépassant
les frontières partisanes a voulu mettre
en oeuvre dans un souci d'unité mesure
et vous le savez bien qui a coûté à la
gauche la menace terroriste reste très
élevé sur notre territoire
mais l'union nationale du coup n'existe
plus si elle a raté la serrure east on
répond par des mesures pratiques qui
sont celles d'un meilleur équipement
d'un meilleur armement de nos services y
compris en terme de personnels
compétents des linguistes en nombre
suffisant des gens qui savent faire la
différence entre l'arabe de mauritanie
l'arabe d'irak
tout ce dont malheureusement nos
services sont largement privé
aujourd'hui aux terroristes on répond en
les prenant pour ce qu'ils sont c'est à
dire des criminels qui mérite la réponse
que doivent avoir les et la gauche doit
l'habiter barbare mais je suis cohérent
la déchéance de nationalité c'est vrai
manuel valls a raison de dire ça avait
été proposée par la droite en son temps
mais j'avais déjà à l'époque exprimé que
je n'étais pas d'accord avec ces
propositions et puis dans la philosophie
de la faire le sujet de la france
aujourd'hui y compris pour affirmer
notre identité notre force
la résilience des français dans la lutte
contre eta
il sait dire ce qu'est être français et
non pas ce qui est en sortir
je suis pour le droit du sang parce
c'est ça la bonne réponse c'est dire ce
qu'est être français
l'enjeu de notre pays c'est dire comment
on est français que dix n'ont pas
vraiment vous prive dans l'être une
prend soin fillon a eu cette remarque ce
vendredi la cité l'exemple de manuel
valls qui qualifie de manoeuvrier sans
envergure vous irait jusque là aussi
nous c'est pas le sujet enfin je crois
que c'est pas le sujet heureux tout cela
oui mais non mais je dis pas ça voyez
vous pas ce que je pense que c'est la
mesure elle même qui s'effondre dire qu
un symbole qui embraye sur une réalité
alors ça vaut la peine je ne récuse pas
toute idée de symbole mais on m'a dit
mme hervé c'est important c'est un
symbole un symbole pourquoi un symbole
pour rien et bien un symbole qui nombre
est sûr que les mesures concrètes à un
moment ça s'effondre là comme
s'effondrer au fond méditons cette leçon
que la politique résumer à de la
communication sans embrayage dans la
réalité des considérations de la droite
qui par manque de courage n'ose pas
expliquer aux français
eh ben l'excès de communication la
suffisance de pédagogie à un moment
faire valoir et on vous avez vu que le
premier ministre des prêts aux sénateurs
on va coûter quelques sénateurs
justement qui aurait agi à cela le
prénom de la république a joué avec le
feu il veut faire porter la
responsabilité sur les autres alors que
c'est sa responsabilité propre son rôle
c'était de réunir avant de s'engager
les différents présidents de chambres du
parlement mais aussi les présidents de
groupe pour caler les choses avant et
pas après en réalité il a co ce qu'ils
méritent
la priorité de nos concitoyens ce n'est
pas cette révision constitutionnelle ce
sont les problèmes de sécurité ce sont
les problèmes de chauffe
ce sont les problèmes de pouvoir d'achat
et ce texte c'est la manière dont ils
avaient été lancés démontre que ça ne
répondait pas aux priorités des français
qu' il est sage aujourd'hui de tourner
cette page à tourner la page jeux
politiciens
ça suffit c'est vrai qu'on a perdu
beaucoup de temps avec une mesure
inefficace et inopérant tôt que
travaillons sérieusement la lutte contre
le terrorisme et travaille au service de
six jours c'est dans l'assemblée non je
rentre s'arrête on évoque quand même
toujours là une révision de la
constitution possible sur un autre sujet
celui de la réforme du conseil supérieur
de la magistrature est ce que pour vous
c'est indispensable ou pas donc ce n'est
pas indispensable à ma connaissance sur
la période la plus récente l'exécutif
n'a jamais passé mais j'allais passer
outre l'avis du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature y compris à l'égard des
magistrats du parquet on a autre chose à
faire enfin ya plein de choses qui
marchent pas en france c'est un auteur
mais a raison de dire dans le domaine de
l'économie de l'emploi du chômage donc
pas la révision du conseil supérieur de
magistrature par la grue constitutionnel
peau je conserverai franchement il n'y a
pas de nécessité de réformes
institutionnelles en france aujourd'hui
ni aujourd'hui ni demain d'accord on va
passer à un autre sujet pendant ce temps
là le cdh a examiné le projet de loi sur
la réforme pénale ils ont adopté le
principe d'une perpétuité incompressible
ça veut dire une mesure qui permettrait
de porter la période de sûreté jusqu'à
pour les théories jusqu'à 30 ans de
prison
tous les détails des explications avec
faustine saint geniès un texte plus
musclée et plus sévères s'il emprunte
apportées au projet de loi urvoas par le
sénat à majorité de droite et du centre
objectif donner davantage de moyens
d'enquêté d'action contre le terrorisme
parmi les mesures emblématiques voulue
par les républicains la fameuse
perpétuité réelle qui est en fait un
allongement de la période de sûreté dans
le respect de la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme et de la
constitution nous sommes allés au plus
loin qu'il est possible d'aller la
période de sûreté a été portée de 22 ans
à 30 ans autre modification controversée
la création de deux nouveaux délits le
délit de consultation de sites
terroristes
puni de deux ans de prison et 30 mille
euros d'amande et le délit de séjour sur
un théâtre d'opérations terroristes
certains socialistes regrettent qu'une
surenchère sécuritaire
lange
pense qu'on n'est pas du tout dans un
pragmatisme on est dans un affichage
comment est ce que la justice arrivera à
assimiler et à utiliser tous les délits
toutes les infractions nouvelle que vous
essayez de mettre en oeuvre un texte
crucial pour le gouvernement alors que
l'état d'urgence arrive à échéance le 26
mai prochain
est ce que ce texte correspond à vos
attentes oui je crois qu'il ya des
mesures qui sont justifiés et qui sont
nécessaires dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et les sénateurs de droite
ont eu raison
je vais observer par exemple sur les
mots vains soyons précis il s'agit pas
de perpétuité réelle
il s'agit d'une augmentation de la
période de sûreté et de faire en sorte
qu'une décision de justice soit
nécessaire et qu'il n'y ait pas de
libération automatique à un moment donné
mais donc que la perpétuité soit
encadrée de cette manière là je trouve
que les sénateurs voit juste pour être
très honnête à l'égard des français
arrivent tombe d'appeler sa perpétuité
réelle parce que ça ne l'est pas non
mais reconnaissez que c'est un peu
curieux c'est confond tout le monde
parle de ça on se dit que oui mais c'est
ça qui nous va très bien je je je suis
un esprit un peu rigoureux qu'est-ce
qu'ils iraient à la place qu est-ce que
vous semez mais je trouve que ce qui a
été voté par le sénat va bien à vous
je dis simplement ce n'est pas par une
remarque qui est
arrêtons de vendre au français de la
fausse monnaie parce que les français
avant ils s'en rendent compte et isin
c'est quoi ces gens c'est pas sérieux
nous allons jouer la période de sûreté
nous rendons plus difficile
l'élargissement de personnes nous ont
sortis n'ai rien d'automatique avec une
décision de justice qui sera très
difficile à obtenir pour le condamner
mais pas totalement impossible donc faut
juste et honnête dans les matelas aurait
elle enfin voilà quoi
alors ce texte instaure des mesures
censées servir quand l'état d'urgence
aura cessé en france
est ce que pour vous elles sont
parfaitement suffisante pour permettre
aux forces de l'ordre de réagir à temps
pour arrêter par exemple quelqu'un comme
reda cricket c'est suffisant il ne
manque rien
moteur et je viens je serait bien
imprudent a vous d il le manque rien
seulement il faut pas qu'on soit
uniquement dans cette logique de loi
supplémentaire je pense qu'ils aient
besoin de moyens et je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure des exemples extrêmement
technique est aussi une question un
enjeu
je l'expliqué dans mon livre de
mobilisation de l'ensemble des
populations il vaut la peine de regarder
comment des pays sous la menaces
répétées de terrorisme
contex différents royaume uni israël
sont des pays sont des démocraties qui
vivent ou les gens vont aux spectacles
vont à la plage vont restos vont en
boîte vont au boulot et en même temps
sont très attentifs à la lutte contre
l'intolérance doit ces affaires de
vigilance sur ce qui se passe dans
certains quartiers c'est à faire le
suivi de personnes s'est refermé sur dix
citoyens
juste un exemple je n'ai pas voté la loi
renseignement il ya quelques mois
pourquoi parce que la logique de la
loire enseignement c est temps de le
filer plus en plus large
or on voit bien avec les terroristes qui
ont été mis en cause ces derniers mois
que ce soit à bruxelles à paris sont des
gens qui étaient déjà dans le radar donc
il faut c'est ça dont je conçois
beaucoup plus efficace à suivre des gens
qui soient dans le radar plutôt que
d'être dans une espèce de surenchère
perpétuelle qui consiste à élargir le
radar à étendre le filet plus loin y
compris parfois en mettant en cause un
son de libertés publiques
je suis pas chaud chaud hot et en même
temps je suis attaché aux libertés
publiques
surtout je cherche l'efficacité
l'exemple de la loire enseignement est
intéressant à cet égard est temps de le
radar est temps de le filer sa pas
beaucoup d'intérêt voire même ça fait
beaucoup compliqué les choses
de nouveau un peu comme la déchéance ça
fait chic on dit aux gens regardez on
les courageux on prend des vraies
mesures
et puis la réalité derrière elle est un
peu modeste faut se réveiller
il faut surtout y avoir une action juste
bien calibré mobiliser aussi les
citoyens la lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est la sphère de tuer votre sujet
capteurs michel sapin cherche lui aussi
à avoir plus d'efficacité il a présenté
mercredi son nouveau projet de loi en
conseil des ministres nommés sapin deux
missions lutter contre la corruption
dans les entreprises à alex pichon en
matière de transparence et de lutte
contre la corruption la france a du
retard à rattraper sur 104 pays notés
elle se classe seulement à la 23e place
faute absolument rompre le cercle de la
défiance entre les citoyens et les
acteurs publics ou privés tout d'abord
le texte prévoit la création d'une
agence nationale de détection et de
prévention de la corruption
ce n'est pas un machin administratives
de plus mais bien un organisme au large
pouvoir chargé de conseiller de forme et
de contrôler et de sanctionner le cas
échéant en plus de la protection des
lanceurs d'alerté de la création d'un
registre de lobbies
la future agence placé sous l'autorité
des ministères de la justice et des
finances sera aussi chargée de
surveiller les entreprises de plus de
500 salariés et dont le chiffre
d'affaires est supérieur à 100 millions
d'euros ces entreprises devront mettre
en oeuvre des procédures de détection et
de prévention des faits de corruption ou
de trafic d'influencé
l'autre volet du texte concerne lui la
modernisation de la vie des entreprises
les auto entrepreneurs pourront
notamment continuer à bénéficier d'un
régime fiscal simplifié pendant deux ans
et ce même en cas de bons chiffres
d'affaires
en revanche ce qui devait être la
disposition phare la transaction pénale
a été retoqué par le conseil d'état est
ce que pour vous et hervé mariton et y
avait besoin d'une loi comme celle ci
est ce que cette agence nationale de
détection et de prévention de la
corruption ne sera pas un comité
théodule droit il ya quelques occasions
manquées le dernier point qui a été
évoqué on pouvait espérer développement
de la capacité de faire des auto
entrepreneurs le texte est en réalité
beaucoup plus précis fait loin pour
espérer que ça ne va pas assez loin
l'auto-entrepreneur c'était une bonne
idée du précédent mandat
c'est dommage que le gouvernement n'est
pas le courage de faciliter encore et
sur l'imprimé de la dynamique de
l'entreprise sur le reste lutter contre
la corruption si tout à fait bienvenu
l'économie de marché au passage est la
meilleure manière de lutter contre la
corruption
quand vous avez des économie administrée
regardez le scandale petrobras au brésil
avec un pays qui a une économie trop
administrés eh bien vous voyez la
situation dans laquelle se trouve la
présidente brésilienne aujourd'hui car
plus l'économie est administré plus vous
avez de la corruption
regardez aussi en russie donc je dis ça
le libéral que je suis sait ce qu'il dit
et quand j'entends parfois des gens à
gauche ou à droite disent oh il faudrait
plus de régulation oulala l'europe c'est
une catastrophe
oh là là la concurrence non non vous
demandez-vous leur linge sale et bien la
réalité c'est que le plus fière
dirigisme qu'ils soient français ou
européens où vous le mettez le plus haï
de corruption michel sapin a raison
lutter contre la corruption
c'est simplement une observation c'est
qu'il faut à la fois lutter contre la
corruption lutter contre la fraude
fiscale
faisons attention que un certain nombre
d' équilibre budgétaire aujourd'hui dans
l'exécution du budget de l'état sont
assurés par les bonnes nouvelles
extérieur type bas taux d'intérêt
prix du pétrole bas mais aussi par un
meilleur rendement de la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale
ça c'est très bien en soi
il faut pas que ça devienne le seul
paramètre d'ajustement du budget parce
que sinon on risque de se trouver avec
des services pour les objectifs
quantitatifs et avant vous pouvez avoir
un problème de relation avec les
contribuables et de mépris de l'équipe
de la relation de les services fiscaux
les contribuables entreprises ou parking
voilà pour ce sujet on va passer au
jeudi c'était jour de grève et de
manifestations il était un petit peu
plus de plusieurs milliers en tout cas
dans les rues de france a manifesté le
mot d'ordre évidemment c'était la
suppression du projet de loi travail
le gouvernement dit entendre mais en
tout cas ne veut compte pas céder 7 les
explications de jérôme bonnard cet après
midi dans toute la france selon la cgt
et force ouvrière
ils étaient deux fois plus au moins que
le 9 mars dernier
plus rien ne freine la mobilisation ni
la pluie ni les modifications du texte
de la loi travail annoncé lundi 14 mars
par le premier ministre manuel valls
aujourd'hui le ton se durcit et vise
toute la classe politique
je pense que les parlementaires au delà
du gouvernement les parlementaires eux
aussi doivent écouter le mécontentement
est donc ils doivent dire on recommence
à zéro
ils doivent dire au gouvernement il faut
recommencer à zéro ce projet de loi
n'est pas bon et donc il faut
retravailler un vrai code du travail
moderne qui protège les salariés sans
l'obtention de nouveaux droits sociaux
il ne reste pour les centrales
protestataires presque aucune marge de
négociation avec le gouvernement voyant
public a été sage hier il a retiré son
projet sur la déchéance de nationalité
bas frais qu'il soit sage aujourd'hui
aussi qu'ils comprennent que il faut
retirer ce projet doit et qu'on re met
tout sur la table qu'on rediscute on n'a
jamais dit qu'on était pour le status
quo mais il faut rediscuter au fond du
dossier
la cgt a promis en fin de journée
d'amplifier l'action
les grèves les manifestations notamment
le 5 avril en direction des
parlementaires
le samedi 9 avril et après jusqu'au
retrait de ce projet de loi
alors avec murray temps je vous présente
jean ferrat c'est notre partenaire du
scan
d'ailleurs ces deux ans aujourd'hui bon
anniversaire qin
on va revenir à deux petites minutes de
bord qui tient sur le fond sur les
manifestations
oui une question nouvelle journée
d'action et de grève y en aura d'autres
promet la cgt bientôt la rue aura-t-elle
raison de la réforme elle conneries pour
vous la rue surtout la cohérence du
gouvernement fait que la loi va être
vidé des quelques éléments intéressants
qui pouvait y avoir dedans c'est pas
imprévisible puisque de toute manière
les quelques progrès j'ai dit à l'ats
que la loi était insuffisante j'y
reviens de régler quelques problèmes
peut y avoir deux dents n'étaient
d'évidence pas annoncée dans le
programme de françois hollande en 2012
donc faire les choses trop différente de
ce que vous annoncer au monde élections
ça fonctionne pas normalement
la réalité se venge mais moi je trouve
que là la vision que je propose on a
évoqué tout à l'air beaucoup plus
audacieuse la suppression du code du
travail au sens où partout où on peut
trouver un accord dans l'entreprise cet
accord doit prévaloir
et bien ça c'est une vision ça ça donne
véritablement un objectif possible
un espoir aussi des progrès à espérer au
sein de chaque entreprise et avec une
réforme audacieuse comme celle que je
propose à mon avis vous n'avez pas les
manifs que vous avez là quand ya pas de
vision quand vous avez cette logique de
dérogation garde les 35 heures mais on
essaye de tourner autour du truc sur les
prud'hommes
on veut encadrer les décisions mais pas
trop au fond d'alcoolisme et un chiffre
pas contraignant au l'économie en
réalité l'emploi les salaires et les
entreprises ne gagne rien mais vous avez
tous les motifs du monde pour manifester
avec barrette ont tout le monde demande
le retrait est ce que vous aussi vous
demande aujourd'hui le retrait de ce
texte
non je suis pas dans ce cadre-là d'abord
je ne suis pas présent la république la
gauche à droite pour le cabba non mais
il ya dans ce texte je le dis sondes de
mesure autre oeuvre est utile mais
attendez moi je ne voterai pas cessé
pour ça si vous ne votez pas malgré le
retrait par retrait c'est un jeu entre
le gouvernement et sa majorité
c'est pas mon sujet mon sujet c'est de
dire que l'enjeu de l'emploi est
évidemment tout à fait considérable dans
notre pays et que d'autres pays en
europe et dans le monde s'en sorte mieux
et que ça ne peut mieux fonctionné en
france qu'avec une vision beaucoup plus
au deuxième un homme de l'année un homme
ou une femme qui la porte dit il manque
à la france peut-être un matteo renzi
mme margaret thatcher ou ou un hervé
mariton mais écoutez j'utilise en tout
cas qu'il manque
surtout à la france l'audace dans la
liberté la force des valeurs c'est vrai
que je suis celui qui porte ce projet je
suis donc l'homme de la situation allait
voilà on passe au scanner la loupe du
scan c'est avec jaime jara ces voix là
jim c'est à vous et de 10 ça aurait
mariton geoffroy didier vient de
s'ajouter cette semaine à la longue
liste des candidats à la primaire dans
laquelle vous figurer est ce que cette
multiplication des candidatures ne
démonétise pas un peu le l'engagement
que représente le fait d'être candidat
là la halle à la présidence de la
république à l'elysée oui je suis
candidat à l'élection présidentielle par
les primaires sur la base d'un projet
d'une passion d'un engagement d'un
combat que je mène
d'autres pourraient mener se trouve que
d'autres ne le mène pas sur cette
exigence de liberté et de valeurs qui
serait plus banal probablement dans
d'autres pays qui s'en sortent mieux que
nous mais en france il ya toujours une
certaine hésitation par rapport à la
liberté un pays qui s'est construit avec
beaucoup de dirigisme par rapport aux
valeurs un pays
hélas très complexée par rapport à son
nid d'entités je porte cela parce que
c'est indispensable une ligne j'ai déjà
cinq candidats ou clients neva je
porterai d'accord qui dit plus de
candidats dit aussi moins de parrainage
disponible c'est mathématique vous devez
en récolter 20 de la part de
parlementaires vous on est tous très
précisément aujourd'hui mais aucun
candidat n'a aucun aujourd'hui monsieur
tout simplement monsieur les formula de
parrainage n'ont pas été emportés nombre
sont cités par tel ou tel candidat quand
vous discutez a été parlementaire en
question voir et c'est plus compliqué je
vous rappelle que j'avais eu plus de
cinquante parlementaires
les soutiens au monde la présidence de
l'ump que je suis dans une relation
fluide avec mes collègues je ne les
harcèle pas en même temps le temps
maintenant avance et en effet je suis
dans une démarche et les formulaires
sont disponibles à la fin du mois
d'avril qui consiste à demander aux uns
et aux autres de confirmer leur position
leur bonne engagement à mon égard dont
je suis sera en même temps c'est un
travail auquel je suis aussi attentif
mais je veux juste vous dire je reviens
sur cette affaire du nombre de candidats
à la primaire républicaine aux états
unis au début il y avait plus d'une
vingtaine de candidats
la presse américaine plus courageuses et
plus travailleuse peut-être que la
presse française a été capable
d'organiser des débats
ce facebook c'est pas des débutants avec
dix sept candidats en deux séquences en
prime time
le soir les 10 les mieux cotés mais oui
parce que ça serait bien pour quoi vous
laisser enfermer dans l'idée qu'au fond
ce chiffre est insurmontable
moi je trouve que mes regardée aux états
unis ça fonctionne plutôt bien
de même que yi pas joey liste tous les
trois vous êtes très talentueux mais qui
vous disent aujourd'hui de toute manière
vous pensez tous la même chose donc
d'abord ya pas de raison qu il tente
candidats pour prôner le mot de nicolas
sarkozy qu est dit enfin pas vous mais
certains journalistes
la semaine dernière nicolas sarkozy dit
c'est un cirque et du raïs qui disent
certains s'y est un signe de récents
vous dit
certains d'entre vous pas vous vous êtes
les meilleurs mais d'autre part
construction vous dites tous la même
chose évidemment ça vous dispense de
lire les bouquins et savoir ce qu'on dit
précisément épaves ou non il y en a en
tout cas un signe de bonne santé
oui mais il inquiète des idées il ya un
candidat qui a pas besoin de parrainage
il s'agit de jean frédéric poisson sont
sa candidature en tant que candidat du
parti chrétien démocrate et donc pas
candidat des républicains a été validé
cette semaine par le bureau politique
est ce que vous trouvez normal qu'ils
bénéficient d'une sorte de passe droit
techniquement c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça parce que la démarche
centrée sur la candidature de jean
frédéric poisson n'a pas été validé en
tant que tel vous savez les débats que
nous avons eus les blancs être le seul
candidat officiel aujourd'hui c'est pas
comme ça que ça a été présenté par les
républicains donc ça il n'y a pas de y'a
pas de l'oeuf est atteint cela ne met
pas à chercher parce que je pense de
parrainage exactement je parlais de
votre bouquin nous on la lui en tout cas
je vous laisse je le réussis il
s'appelle le printemps des libertés il
se fit un plaisir c'était un grand
plaisir il commence par cette épigraphe
de soljenitsyne vous êtes un russophiles
averti personne sur la terre n'a d'autre
issue que d'aller toujours plus haut
prix vous voulez aller jusqu'au bout
hervé mariton le bonheur de la france le
bonheur des français c'est très haut le
bonheur c'est un objectif très très haut
et c'est ça qui me motive en politique
donc et dont je suis un évident à
réaliser je suis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle parce que je pense que ce
vélo je suis pas né avec la première
fois je me suis rasé
margot les sens je ne suis pas sûr
d'être posé cette question devant la
glace et c'est probablement par rapport
à d'autres et peut-être par rapport à
certains journalistes une tare insoluble
parce que vous n'aimez pas vous j'ai
déjà assez mais en gros la classe
médiatique politique et plus
impressionné par les combattants de
toujours et voire intime qui intervient
dans le débat mais qui a plutôt fait le
boulot jusqu'à présent mais dont un
collègue disait il ya quelques mois
invitant un débat vous verrez le débat
avec marion ça va être passionnant il ya
des idées c'est un type super et en plus
il a une grande qualité il n'a pas
d'ambition et ben voila je présente les
choses différemment parce qu'à un moment
il me paraît indispensable de porter ces
idées ce projet qui me paraît utile à
mon pays
justement parlons d'idées vous proposer
une série de mesures chocs dans votre
livre suppression de du système dh et
l'amusant par email alors suppression du
code du travail vous avez réellement
parler smic modulable franchement
margaret thatcher à côté de vous c'est
une première générale ou plomb vraiment
la 11ème sur la pris du retard doit être
mais je constate simplement qu'il ya des
pays comme le royaume uni vous le site
et qui aujourd'hui s'en sortent mieux
donc j'ai aujourd'hui c'est quoi les
perspectives en france quand c'est la
gauche c'est le déclin rapide quand
c'est la droite c'est le déclin lent
j'ai envie de sortir cancérologique là
et oui je fais des propositions l'impôt
universel et proportionnelle parce qu'on
a besoin d'un système fiscal plus juste
et pas la fausse réforme qui est celle
de la régulation très rapidement pour
terminer nicolas sarkozy a rappelé
encore cette semaine qu'il souhaitait
adopter un programme commun pour le
parti avant la primaire est-ce que vous
l'impression qu'ils essayent de vous
imposer un carcan idéologique excusez
moi monsieur mais corps nicolas sarkozy
continue d'expliquer que les 35 heures
c'est le nirvana en quelque sorte et que
seul sujet c'est les exos de charges par
rapport aux 35 heures quand nicolas
sarkozy dit qu'il faut baisser les
impôts plus vite que les dépenses corps
nicolas sarkozy continue de dire qu'il
faut spécialisé l'économie française au
niveau du smic en mettant tout l'effort
public sur des baisses de charges au
niveau du smic ça ça s'appelle
l'enfermement de l'économie française
dans une vision tir bon disait cette
vision économique je suis radicalement
en désaccord avec c'est dit c'est dit et
c'est terminé merci beaucoup jim
jarrassé merci hervé mariton se retrouve
donc la semaine prochaine katia la
semaine prochaine travaux de ces deux
programmes sur lcp public sénat merci